Gerade hat China die Elektroauto Quote eingeführt und noch mehr innovative Ideen kommen vor allem aus China
Zwar gibt es dort auch den ein oder anderen Pfiff, aber es zeigt sich
Dass sich doch in China am meisten bewegt und auch abseits dieser neuesten Technologien wird auf Chinas Straßen der Verkehr der Zukunft
geplant wie das dort genau läuft welche Entwicklungen geplant sind und was wir uns von den Chinesen in Sachen Mobilität abrufen können und
Am Ende noch ein Geschenk für euch jetzt in Klicks um Science-Fiction herzlich willkommen
wer sich bei uns Beispielsweise über den Täglichen Stau im Ruhrgebiet aufregt war wohl noch nie auf den
Straßen in Chinas unterwegs die Zustände dort sind wirklich
Unvorstellbar Katastrophal 2010 zb gab es rund um Pc. Ein Stau der insgesamt mehr als
18 Tage dauerte unter den Anhaltenden und täglichen Verkehrsprobleme in China leiden nicht nur die Menschen selbst
250 Mikrogramm Feinstaub Belastung sind hier keine Seltenheit dabei sind laut Weltgesundheitsorganisation
Bereits ein Zehntel davon also 25 Mikrogramm
Gesundheitsgefährdend die Menschen in Peking haben alle eine App auf dem Handy
Die Ihnen die aktuelle Luftqualität anzeigt und die ist wie gesagt mehr als Besorgniserregend
Der hoch ist kaum auszuhalten
Er ist beißend und ätzend zugleich über der ganzen Stadt hängt eine
weltliche Dunstglocke für die olympischen Spiele 2008 mussten deshalb Strenge
Verbote erlassen werden und Fabriken wurden für die Zeit der Spiele geschlossen und danach wurde es nicht besser man traut sich kaum einzuordnen
Dieser Zustand hat den Peking übrigens schon einen eigenen Namen
Erpo Calypso und durch den Smog gibt es am Ende auch tote. Es gibt Schätzungen nach denen
1,6 Millionen Menschen Pro Jahr in China durch diese Luftverschmutzung einen verfrühten Tod sterben kein Wunder, also
Dass die Chinesen viele innovative Ideen bezüglich des Verkehrs der Zukunft haben auf der Internationalen Hightech Messe in Peking
Wurde im Mai vergangenen Jahres das Verkehrsmittel der Zukunft
präsentiert der Tb der
Bi der Trends survey bas ein riesiger Bus der über den Staus aus den Autos unter ihm hinüber gleitet
Zudem noch elektrisch angetrieben und somit kein weiterer Smog Verstärker für Chinas Straßen einige
Verkehrsexperten Weltweit und auch viele Medien waren im Ti bier aus endlich einmal ein
Unkonventionelles mutiges und innovatives Projekt was nach Meinung einiger Experten auch für alle anderen Großstädte ein absolutes Must-have sei?
doch wenig später dann die riesige Enttäuschung der TB ein riesiger bluff die
Verantwortlichen sitzen wegen Betrug eine Haftstrafe, ab der Prototyp ist längst verrostet und die Teststrecke abgerissen Medien
Sehen einen umfassenden Anlagebetrug hinter der ganzen Geschichte
Doch, die Idee war ehrlich gesagt auch zu schön um wahr zu sein auch eine weitere Innovative Idee aus China wurde nie zur Realität
Eine neue Spezies des Autos wurde uns versprochen
Der ewn ein Team an ein Elektroauto als direkte Konkurrenz zu tesla durch seine 1050 Ps
Sollte der FV an laut Plan in weniger als 2 3 9 Sekunden von 0 auf 100 Stundenkilometer
Beschleunigen die Idee Kam von dem amerikanischen Startup Farideh future viel Geld kam zusätzlich vom vorsitzenden des chinesischen
Elektronik Konzerns liegt die Reichweite
600 Kilometer möglich gemacht durch Lithium Ionen Batterien mit 130 Kilowattstunden
290.000 Dollar ein Schnäppchen
Dachten sich offenbar viele denn bereits 36 Stunden nach der Präsentation gab es bereits rund
64.000 Vorbestellung
2018 sollte das Elektroauto auf den Markt kommen 5000 Dollar musste jeder interessent direkt an zahlen doch
Das ist mittlerweile mehr als ungewiss denn das Lazarett future scheint auf sehr wackligen Beinen zu stehen sein
Großinvestor Beispielsweise scheint in
Zahlungsschwierigkeiten zu stecken auch für eine dritte, Idee die erst einmal durch die Decke schoss gab es ein eher ernüchterndes
Ende zumindest bisher der elektrische Passagier Multipler haben 184 sollte laut Plan
23 Minuten in der Luft bleiben und in eine Höhe von Rund drei Kilometern kommen
Das Ziel sollte man einfach per App ansteuern können ein Kontrollzentrum sollte sich um Start Flug und Landung kümmern in diesem Juli
Sollten die Lufttaxis an den Start gehen doch bis auf einige geglückte Testflüge gab es noch keine Erfolgsmeldung
Was aber erstmal noch nicht so viel bedeutet drei Fallbeispiele aber auf jeden Fall die darauf hinweisen
dass die Ideen der chinesischen Entwickler und entwicklerinnen super Innovativ sind sie diese allerdings nicht liefern können zumindest nicht so schnell wie
Angekündigt dabei ist China laut Meinung vieler
Forschungsteams
Tatsächlich das Land das die Mobilität der Zukunft wird bestimmt zum Einen weil China zur Technologie Nation aufsteigen will aber zum anderen auch
aus der eigenen not heraus die drei
Gescheiterten Projekte, die ich bisher vorgestellt habe sehen viele Experten, deswegen nicht als Beweis dafür an
Dass chinesisch für Ideen zum Scheitern verurteilt sind stattdessen sei dies ein Indiz dafür
Dass Technik basierte Innovationen aus China in den letzten Jahren Stark zugenommen haben unter anderem auch
Weil die Regierung Start-ups aus der Privatwirtschaft
Unterstützt ein Wahrhaftiges prestige Objekt aus China, Allerdings ist die Elektromobilität
2020 Soll es mehr als fünf Millionen Elektroautos auf Chinas straßen geben Peking hat jetzt gerade ein Gesetz durchgebracht
Das den Verkauf von Elektroautos sogar anordnen
Autohersteller in China müssen Bereits in zwei Jahren eine feste Elektro Quote von 10 erfüllen oder aber als
Strafzahlung leisten so produzieren nicht nur die chinesischen Automarkt eifrig Elektroautos auch audi BMW und volkswagen stellen Ihre
Modellpalette um Weltweit Stammen Rund 40 Prozent aller Elektroautos aus chinesischer Produktion so eine Studie von McKinsey
0,25 Prozent so hoch oder besser niedrig war in diesem Jahr die Chance auf ein neues Nummernschild in Peking in Shanghai dagegen
Laxey immerhin bei 4 Prozent für ein los musste man dafür aber rund
11.000 Euro bezahlen je nach änderung des Nummernschilds gibt es zudem auch festgelegte Tage im Monat in
Denen die entsprechenden Autos nicht gefahren werden dürfen
Sondern abwechselnd in der Garage stehen müssen ein ganz großes Ding in China Städten ist die Shared Mobility hier wird, also
Geteilt busse Autos und Fahrräder und das in einem Ausmaß
Wie man es sich bei uns kaum vorstellen kann 20 Millionen fahrten Pro Tag gehen auf das Konto des Chinesischen Pompons?
Im Vergleich dazu, aber kommt in New York pro Tag auf 200.000 fahrten selbst, wenn man berücksichtigt
Dass mehr Menschen in Peking als in New York leben ist ober damit mehr als
Abgeschlagen und auch Fahrräder werden natürlich geteilt mit dem Handy wird es geortet und man umgeht
Damit den Stau für eine Stunde hat man umgerechnet 12 Cent und dass das alles sinn macht
Das ist mittlerweile auch in den Köpfen der Chinesen angekommen
Es gibt Studien nach denen sich 40 Prozent der Menschen dort vorstellen, können sich kein eigenes Auto zu kaufen
Ja, und jetzt gibt es ein Geschenk für euch wie versprochen in Zusammenarbeit mit der Redaktion von Technology Review
einen ganz fantastischen
Zeitschrift ist dieses Video entstanden und Ecstasy für pixum zuschauer habe ich jetzt eine Ausgabe gratis
Wenn ihr auf diesen Link klickt
Dann bekommt er sie ist lohnt sich kann ich nur sagen der klassische Review ist wirklich
Mega spannend und hier geht es zu einem weiteren Video, das wir mit der Reaktion gemacht haben 3D Druck revolutioniert die Raumfahrt Klick drauf
Wenn es euch interessiert und ansonsten bis dann
Bleibt dran